Design Thinking is for all ages the
different levels of professionalism
teaching design different from teaching
let's say physics it's about discovery
so you have to construct the problem the
problem is not a given you have to
discover actually what you want to see
in the solution that's part of the
design doing design itself there's an
emphasis not just on the result but on
the process as well on the product and
actually in in our university education
but also in schools we evaluate the
product the process and the presentation
one of the biggest things that change in
teaching is that the outcome is not
predefined and that's really scary for
many teachers and it would be scary for
it was scary for me when I first had to
teach in design and then in design there
is no answers page there isn't even a
criteria for a good solution children
are creative but you should not confuse
the fact that they still draw that they
are expressive with creative in design
often creativity means you can make
something which is new and relevant if
it's only new and totally silly that
doesn't work
empathy and evaluating what you made the
manufacturers of airplane seats used to
work two specs and actually the only
thing they got was dimensions so many
centimeters like this and so far apart
two years ago for the first time they
build a prototyping lab for people to
sit and to try stuff out making stuff
tangible you learn such a lot and part
of the design skills is to keep that in
mind not forget it as you turn the page
and visual formats can greatly help
their design is very much a
collaborative effort so there's a lot of
communication going on how do we plan it
and a lot of giving critique to each
other saying what's good but also how
things could be different now the 21st
century skills be creative think
critically solve problems communicate
make into your plan empathize and
collaborate make mistakes because
mistakes are the only way to learn you
have to try out many things and many
things don't work and actually it's the
only way to learn
[Music]